hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery Gabriele Marcel will
have a somewhat extended discussion of
three closely related themes despair
betrayal and suicide he talks about
these and analyzes them and much greater
depth in other works but he's going to
bring them up here in in part to
illustrate what he's what he's calling
the dramatic character of existence he's
also talking about them as human
possibilities possibilities that you
might say are part of the existential
condition for us at every point but
which can be exacerbated by all sorts of
other factors including the type of a
world and culture and civilization that
we live within so he tells us that he
says perhaps some will be surprised to
find such emotionally-charged
fashionable words as suicide and
betrayal in the midst of a common
abstract analysis why are you talking
about this sort of thing he says well
this is no concession to sensationalism
I am firmly convinced that as in drama
and through drama that met
physical thought becomes conscious and
defines itself concretely and he brings
up Jacques Mara 10 another kind of
existentialist figure he was a
representative of what we sometimes call
existentialist tome ISM and Mara 10 in
his his discussion about Christian
philosophy said there's nothing easier
for a philosophy than to be tragic it
need only yield to the weight of the
human condition and Marcel says he has
Heidegger in mind with that perhaps but
really the the big problem for us is to
be not tragic because at least tragedy
has some sort of meaning and when we're
talking about despair or we're talking
about suicide these are coming about in
large part not because there is some big
tragic confluence in which a person can
actually make sense of their life
tragedy is still meaningful and so
Marcel says that I find on the contrary
philosophy naturally inclined towards
realms where the tragic dimension has
simply meliha disappeared evaporated by
its contact with abstract thought and
because people ignore the person and
sacrifice it to I know what not ideal
truth to what anonymous principle of
pure inwardness they're unable to grasp
the tragic dimensions of human life they
exile them to some disreputable suburb
where a philosopher worthy of the name
doesn't deign to go and so Marcel says
we don't want to do philosophy in that
way we want to take these things
seriously and he says if I have stressed
despair betrayal and suicide it is
because so he's telling us here the
reason the key why it is that he's
talking about this we find in them the
most obvious expressions of a will to
negation brought to bear effectively on
being now there's a couple things that
are important to point out here one is
he's not saying that these are the only
manifestations of such a will to
negation right he's just saying these
are some rather
obvious ones and notice that it's a will
- negation it's not a automatic thought
that must be followed
- negation there's a choice involved
here not a choice that one can you know
simply make looking at all the options
in front of oneself and say oh well I'm
not going to do negation I'm going to do
affirmation or something else but it is
still involving human responsibility
this this is really an existentialist
choice about where to commit oneself how
to view the world how to view oneself so
a will - negation that is applied to
being it's good if we think about the
despair part first I think that's the
easiest way to get into this discussion
but I will mention one thing about
suicide which is that Marcel giving this
talk in the 30s is saying something that
other philosophers will come up with a
little bit later and that is that
suicide is indeed a metaphysical
question he says one could say that in
this sense the permanent possibility of
suicide the fact that at any given point
a person however seemingly fortified
they are however filled with grace they
might be could at some point go in the
other direction and go far enough to
where they would actually attempt or
even succeed in suicide that is a
constant possibility not a probability
but a possibility so he says the
permanent possibility of suicide is an
essential starting point for authentic
metaphysical thought now to come back to
despair
what is despair for a long time despair
has been understood as one of the many
different human emotions and Marcel
thinks that it is an emotional state but
it also has some important cognitive
aspects to it it represents an attitude
towards being
and the entire range of beings it is a
metaphysical state as well as a moral
state so he talks about authentic
despair or absolute despair as an act by
which one despairs of reality as a whole
obviously there's other possibilities
for despair I missed the bus
I feel hopeless I feel despairing
because I'm not gonna make it to the job
interview and without the job interview
in a tough economy I'm not gonna be able
to get myself out of my little rat trap
apartment and start moving on with my
life and it's one more damn thing in a
succession of setbacks to myself right
that's that's not necessarily despair
about the totality of existence but it
could easily fit into that couldn't it
and it does for many people so an act by
which one despairs of reality as a whole
and Marcel devotes a little bit of
analysis to here to this here and and
tells us what that is is like he says
despair announces itself as the
consequence or the expression of a
certain balance sheet you're totaling up
reality is it is it good does it suck
that you know these are very
contemporary terms right but you can
easily relate them to what he's talking
about
so he says insofar as I can evaluate
reality and after all what lies beyond
my ability to appreciate is for me like
something non-existent I find nothing
that withstands a process of dissolution
that develops at the heart of things and
which my reflection enables me to
recognize and measure now that's a
rather you know philosophical way to
talk about this but let's let's think
our way through this what he's saying is
that when I look at everything I don't
see anything that has any intrinsic
value or meaning to it it's all capable
of being looked at thought about
reflected on broken down into other
component parts related to other you
know far-off ends and
of it really really matters by itself
there's nothing truly there from a moral
or metaphysical perspective and when you
look around the world and each thing
that you look at feels like that
or presents itself like that that is
what despair
can consist in he has another great
expression for this these are economic
terms he says there's nothing in being
to which I can give credit nothing I can
count on no security and then he says
it's a declaration of complete
insolvency there's nothing that I can
say I can trust this I know that I'm not
seeing the whole of this but I can
actually trust it and not in the sort of
New Age you can't trust like give
positivity to the universe and the
universe will give positivity too you
know and the more mundane sort of I
actually know that this light is going
to work or the chalkboard is going to
work for me or go on and on and on I'll
be able to wear this tie again and you
might say well how can you not trust
that sort of thing well you know if you
spend time thinking about the things
that we surround ourselves with they are
kind of absurd quite often it's
surprising that things hang together
it's a kind of miracle that things
aren't in a worse model than they are
and actually Marcel says you know the
great pessimists although they're wrong
about things have actually done us some
valuable service in showing us that
things are not the wonderful Pollyannish
or totally reliable bits of you know
data so the way they are sort of in a
computer game you know you go and you
pick up your gun and it works the way
the algorithms have said and you pick up
the ammo for it you pick up your food
thing that replenishes your life right
if you're in in some video game one bit
of chicken is like another bit of
chicken but if you're in real life that
bit of chicken if it's not cooked right
might actually give you a food poisoning
or Salmonella or it doesn't taste the
way it should
when you're trying to cook it it curls
up on the edges and and there's always
reasons why and we could go on and on
and I don't want to get too far into
that but he talks about not only an
objective status or side to this but
also looking at oneself he talks about a
non coincidence
between one's being and one's life and
he says that you can take a look at your
life and at life in general not not only
your life but others lives and say that
they're inadequate and not just an
adequate at the moment you know at this
life stage or before I graduate or you
know until I meet the ideal person or
anything like that but inadequate for
good another way people talk about this
is that no matter what they are no
matter what they do they will never be
good enough they will never be enough
for themselves for others for the world
perhaps even forgot this is part of the
attitude of despair as Marcel is
sketching it out and he tells us that
despair can come in many different forms
it doesn't always have to be an absolute
despair it could be centered more on one
thing than another and it comes with
many degrees of intensity we can have a
sort of low-grade despair churning away
all the time in the background as part
of the you know soundtrack of our life
you might say
Marcel loved musical metaphors so in
this case it would be something like a
drone imagine some unpleasant sound
that's always there Marcel thinks that
the act of despair has a relation to the
functionalized world and he doesn't just
think that it's you know the case that
this sort of world where we are reduced
to function
can bring us to despair he also thinks
that because it's a world of problems
and techniques or technology however you
want to translate that term that we
reduce everything to we sort of flatten
out the world perspective that we can we
can fall into despair through that and
we can do so even in moments as he says
of technological optimism where we think
that everything can be solved through
coming up with one more technique one
more algorithm one more platform one
more bit of technology we can solve
everything he says that here we go it's
easy to fall into a kind of despair
because of the fact that we are the prey
of our technics we can't even realize
how far out of control these things can
can get and so those are those kind of
balance each other off we also when we
become aware that the tech you know the
the technical approach to things that we
come to rely on so much that for some of
us it becomes the only approach possible
think about Silicon Valley people who
believe that just by coming up with a
new platform they will solve the world's
problems or that the world's problems
are in fact amenable to that sort of
treatment to begin with when we realize
that that's not the case and we realized
that we don't have the resources to face
up to that that doesn't just scare us
that can make us feel the opposite of
hope despair so betrayal and suicide as
he says are constant possibilities for
us what does he mean by betrayal
betrayal of the ontological exigency or
need within us that we find ourselves
not always capable of articulating or
understanding well let alone responding
to appropriately and we find ourselves
to some degree resource lists nests in a
world that seems full
of all sorts of shallow resources this
is closely connected with despair now he
tells us and and here he's harkening
back to earlier treatments of despair in
earlier Christian thought that despair
has an opposite and that opposite is
indeed hope he will devote a lot of
discussion to hope the last thing that
we need to realize from ourselves that
within every situation where despair is
a possibility or even an actuality or if
we go beyond that where it's not merely
an actuality but it is the status quo it
is the situation that we are inevitably
in there is also the possibility of
going outside or beyond this he says
there is a correlation between hope and
absolute despair that remains until the
very end they appear to me to be
inseparable and he says the world we
live in so centered on functions
facilitates and can even seem to
recommend an absolute despair but it's
only in a situation such as this that
invincible hope can arise here is where
he credits the great pessimist of the
past and he even talks about Nietzsche
as well he says these thinkers prepared
us to understand that absolute despair
might be what it was for Nietzsche on an
infra ontological level and moreover in
an area strewn with mortal perils the
springboard launching point for the
highest affirmation so it is always
possible to hope now this isn't sort of
counseling a buck up buddy or always
look on the bright side of life or
anything like that because that's not
what Marcel means by hope but hope is
the correlative despair and every time
that despair is going on the great
tragedy of it is that the person quite
often precisely because of that despair
can't see the hope that's lingering
there as a possibility in the background
you